what do you know about war they'll tell
you it's about patriotism democracy or
some [ __ ] about the other guy hating our
freedom and you want to know what it's
really about what do you see
a kid from Arkansas doing his patriotic
duty to defend his country I see a
helmet fire retardant gloves body armor
and an m16
I see $17,500 that's what it calls to
outfit one American soldier
over two million soldiers fought in Iraq
and Afghanistan
it costs the American taxpayer of 4.5
billion each year just to pay the
air-conditioning bills for those wars
and that's what war is really about war
is an economy
anybody who tells you otherwise is
either in on it or stupid
breaking news in a major escalation in
tensions between the u.s. and Iran the
top erotic in general has been killed in
an air strike while leaving the Baghdad
Airport potentially bringing this
country to the brink of an all-out war
now when most people hear dire messages
like this on TV they get pretty
frightened but you and I know different
if this escalates to another major war
in the Middle East or hell maybe even
world war 3 this war avenge this is
music to your ears
so put your morals aside because this is
how to sound the shovels of world war
xxx
[Music]
at the height of the Iraq invasion in
2003 the US had around a hundred fifty
thousand soldiers deployed and the US
government doesn't just have to outfit
all these soldiers with seventeen
thousand five hundred dollars of
equipment each no no no no if they want
to win the war and not look like
complete idiots on the international
stage they also have to provide food
housing water plumbing transportation
and everything in between which becomes
a logistical nightmare and here's the
bigger problem the government doesn't
manufacture or provide any of the stuff
so that means at some point in the
process these products and services have
to exchange hands with everyday citizens
like you and I and the way the
government lets citizens and companies
provide these products and services is
through US government contracts and when
it was all said and done the u.s. spent
nearly five trillion dollars on the war
boys if five trillion dollars all that
money had to go to somebody but who sure
you have the giant companies that secure
the big defense contracts like Boeing
Lockheed Halliburton and unless you have
the means of manufacturing a hundred
million dollar fighter jets you pretty
much have a zero percent chance of
competing with little so if we go into
World War three how are you supposed to
make money 'ln see the downside of these
behemoth defense contractors is that
when the US needs small orders of a few
thousand guns here a few pallets of amyl
they're these giant companies aren't
gonna waste their time with it why waste
your time for a few thousand - a few
million dollars in profit when you can
build entire military bases for billions
of dollars why waste the time and
resources of your company for these
small contracts when you have an
eight-figure salary to maintain and four
to twenty year olds in Miami named david
and ephraim this is what they took
advantage of entered war dogs war dogs
are the small guys like you and i when
there are government contracts that the
big boys deemed too small and not worth
their time we pick up the scraps offer a
competitive bid fulfill the contract at
all costs and make a very respectable
profit a bigger 30% is $180,000
would a profit that Boeing and Lockheed
would laugh at but gives us a pretty
nice lifestyle all of this mind you
without ever setting foot on the
battlefield and within David and
efference first year of doing business
together they landed over a hundred of
those gold standard u.s. contracts which
totaled up to over 10 million dollars
Jesus and four to 20 year olds their gun
running business was going pretty well
okay and by 2007 the US were desperate
to supply their Allied forces in
Afghanistan with ammo so David and Efrem
want a contract that would put all their
previous ones to shame 298 million
dollars their secret they were able to
source old substandard unserviceable
Chinese made ammunition sitting in
Albania from the Cold War era the only
problem was the US had an arms embargo
against China so fulfilling a US
contract with Chinese ammo was very
illegal but that didn't stop our very
entrepreneurial war dogs so instead of
just giving up they decide to repackage
the Amasa no one would suspect it came
from China that sounds illegal and they
almost got away with it too if it wasn't
for that bad press going around about 2
20 euros letting a huge military
contract by heavily under bidding their
competitors darn in the end
efrem was sentenced to four years in
federal prison and David to seven months
of house arrest and 14 months of
probation now the important thing to
take away from the story is what it's
that war profiteering can be very
unethical I'm kidding I'm kidding
here's what you really have to take away
number one the military-industrial
complex and US government contracts can
be very profitable for the little guys
the war dogs number two as long as
there's money to be made one can only
assume that there are most likely Bheem
Wars in the future to profit from yeah
so what I'm trying to say is that you're
in a pretty safe industry number three
the bigger the war the more desperate
the government the more bloodshed that
more money there is to be made and
number four the most important thing to
take away from David and Ephraim's
experience to not get caught so let's
say World War three comes around the
corner what are the actual steps for you
to become a war doc and take a very
small but respectable piece of that
military industrial complex pie
now David and Ephraim's 300 million
dollar contract may sound like a lot of
money but here's the thing that 300
million dollar contract accounted for
less than zero point zero zero six
percent on what the US government spent
on war since 2001 so yeah there's plenty
of contracts to go around for US war
Doc's
let's say the army needs some extra
nine-millimeter ammo well the Navy needs
some grenade launchers though post was
basically a Craigslist ad on a central
web site called beta about sam.gov and
from Lehr anyone can visit this website
see what contracts are available and
make a bid with how much they want to
charge for those two examples that I
just gave happen to be actual contracts
that you can pull up right now in fact
this website has nearly a hundred
thousand contracts of all shapes and
sizes from pretty much every department
of the government on there right now
when World War 3 comes around this is
your gold mine this is the website that
you need to scour day and night for
those special wardog opportunities to
make money and when you find that
perfect contract that fits your criteria
of what you can fulfill it's time to
place a bid
now it's time to do some digging this is
where your inner creativity will shine
the government is looking for the lowest
bid to grab the contract soon so how low
can you go
where can you source the weapons or
equipment for the cheapest can you find
out what your competitors are bidding to
get an edge on the competition any
places you can cut corners without the
government noticing once you feel you
have a pretty solid bid it's as simple
as filling out the form they provide on
the contract and emailing it let's say
you want a contract great here's a gold
star but it doesn't end there because
you don't get paid until it's fulfilled
so now it is your duty to make sure that
all cost these contracts get fulfilled
like any other business if you develop a
good relationship with your customers in
this case the US government they'll be
more likely to award you more contracts
in the future job great if you do really
bad especially since your war dog that
doesn't have the same connections and
the government that the big boys have
the government can cancel your contract
altogether sir I need you to work with
us a little on this I'm in the crack in
the world defending your freedom and I
got to work with you if that happens not
only do you lose out on all that money
for that contract you could be screwed
for future contracts as well so needless
to say you have to be prepared to do
whatever it takes to fulfill these
contracts a much like david and ephraim
once you complete your first contract
the US will use the weapons and
equipment you provide to do whatever
does bombing innocent villages leading
US soldiers to their death whatever and
you simply rinse and repeat and enjoy
those sweet wartime profits while others
perish
[Music]
so congratulations give yourself a pat
on back because in just four simple
steps you now have all the tools you
need to profit from World War 3 but like
any other business it's not all sunshine
and rainbows though until the u.s.
launches another major invasion World
War 3 is declared blah blah blah the
governments of the world and their
subsequent contracts aren't going to be
as desperate there won't be as much of a
dire life-or-death demand they'll keep a
closer eye on how well you fulfil the
contracts which of course means less
opportunities and less profit for the
poor old war dogs like you and I so if
you're watching this right now you
better follow suit with the other big
war profiteers and not just prey for war
but push for war you can think of this
video as a part 2 or a more approachable
take for the average citizen to profit
from war if you happen to have a more
flexible sense of morality compared to
the first video I made on the overall
big picture perspective of the business
of war why war so primal to governments
and what the big war profiteers do and
the kind of money that they make which
pretty much puts everything we went over
in this video with the shame so if you
haven't watched that one yet I highly
recommend it and we'll link it below if
you enjoyed this video and learn
something from it all I ask for is two
things but I watch to the end in the
comments below to give the YouTube
algorithm a nice boost because I think
we can all agree that YouTube isn't
gonna push the stuff as much
doing something as simple as leaving a
comment or pressing the like button
really does help out the channel a ton
and I would really appreciate it number
two just subscribe for more videos like
this where we break down past present
and future businesses just like this one
it's free you can unsubscribe whenever
you want and you can even dislike and
leave me your best hate comments in the
future if you want but perhaps the best
part of subscribing is that you're in a
way adding 20 to 30 more hours into your
week because that's around how long it
takes me to make each video free more
time can it get any better than that I
don't think so so go ahead and click
that red button below and I promise you
won't regret it
thank you so much for watching you've
been awesome ajan Jake I'll see you guys
in the next one
[Music]